استشهد عننا اخوي الله يرحمه غيث الشهاده
راح نضلنا كاهنهم ان شاء الله المعنويات
تبعتهم لوز هذا البلوك ستوك انا اسمي احمد
شحادي من مخيم نور شمس وبلق بوني الشيم
الحمد لله انا بخير الحمد لله كيف حال
المخيم بالفيديو المخيم مش بخير يعني
اطلعي محلات تجاريه قاعدين بدوها طبعا شو
ذنب ها المحلات مش عارفين طبعا ليه بيهدم
لانه
احن بنعمل لهم خسائر بعمل لهم خسائر فهم
بينقهر فاحنا الحمد لله احن مفتخرين بهذا
النصر طيب كيف معنويات الناس بالمخيم احمد
يعني بعد ه الخراب للبيوت للشوارع لكل شيء
المعنويات تبعتهم لوز زي ما قالها اسماعيل
تبعنا هذا البلوك ستوك انت قاعد تتفشي
ببلوك شو بدك بهيه يعني راح نضلنا كاهنهم
ان شاء الله واللي بفوت
بموت احمد شباب الكتيبه في المخيم شو بمثل
بالنسبه للاطفال بمثلوا لنا انهم قدوه
احنا عننا هذا هو البطل هم عندهم مثلا
باتمان سبايدر مان مش داار شو احنا عننا
هدول الابطال المقاومين احمد انت كنت
بتتابع استشهاد اولاد جيرانك اولاد مخيم
بالنهايه الفقد كمان طال بيتكم صحيح طال
بيتنا والحمد لله احنا استشهد عنا اخوي
الله يرحمه غيث الشحاده كان كل ما كل ما
احزن اشكيله همي يصير كله شي عندي وكل ما
ابقى مش محتاج مصاري يكي تع خذ تعال معي
وطش يعني حنون علي كان غي ان شاء الله
ملتقى انا واياه بالجنه ان شاء الله احنا
بيتنا الحمد لله يعني رمناه وعادي رجع زي
ما هو امي بدهم يهدو رمنا برزقنا عادي
يعني مش فركان معان بتتخيل هل ممكن الناس
هون تستسلم او بتحكي خلص ما بدنا مقاومه
لا الناس يعني بتقول في مقاومه نحن ان شاء
الله رح ن بقولوا ان شاء الله المقاومه را
تظل ويصير يقولوا المقاومه انتم تاج
عروسنا واحنن بنحي المقاومه احمد انت اخوك
استشهد وبيتكم كمان تعرض للتدمير والوضع
لسه قائم بالمخيم هل ممكن تفكروا بيوم
انكم تتركوا المخيم وتطلعوا لا ولا ب نفكر
بيوم ولا بيوم ولا دقيقه انه نفكر نطلع
برا المخيم ولا مره رح نضلنا على ارض
المخيم حتى الموت ان شاء الله
تعالى